[Music]
this morning we meet two refugees
bringing new flavors and opportunities
to detroit the inspiring couple from
east africa is behind one of the hottest
restaurants in the motor city nancy chen
shows us how they're also creating a
better future for others who are
starting over
along detroit's main drag hello how are
you
flavors of east africa
nadia bere and her husband mamba hamisi
bring the dishes of their native burundi
to the motor city we started to do the
pop-ups before we we opened a restaurant
and you would sell out yes in 30 minutes
people was like
what is this food how do you cook this
food i just put love in it that's it
that community support led the couple to
start their own restaurant this spring
its name baba fair what does baba mean
it's a tree growing
in west africa it grow without water
it's but it's growing
us
coming in this country as refugees we
didn't know anybody but see where we are
now
was forced to flee burundi in 2013 after
facing persecution for her human rights
work defending women it was a challenge
in many ways you don't know anybody
you discover you're pregnant
not only with one kid two kids in a
shelter it was like a new life burundi
central east hamisi was stuck in burundi
unable to get a visa raising their
daughters alone nijin bere found support
at freedom house a haven for asylum
seekers hamisi finally joined her in
detroit two years later but the former
sales and marketing manager didn't speak
english and had trouble getting hired
sadly
everything was going wrong
and then like you know what the only way
to get off this situation is to create a
business i used to say it was a lack of
opportunity and then you try to find
that exit
to
survive
finding their roadmap through family
recipes they crafted balboa fair's menu
together between the two of you who's
the better cook
who runs the kitchen she is she's in the
kitchen
she is he is good to sell my food
the only job i do is to talk
yes
creating good food isn't their only
priority the couple partners with
freedom house and other local groups to
hire refugees from around the world it's
not just a restaurant you say it's also
a gathering place it's also a safe space
that's important to you very important
coming in here with a lack of
opportunities the first thing to have in
america is to get the first job nobody
wants to hire you because you don't
speak the language you don't have the
skills and then people don't have time
for you to teach you baba fe is there to
give everybody who are coming as
refugees in this country the first
chance to know the american work
environment
people like satya duwali who was born in
somalia and is the mother of two i feel
like
with family
they understand me
and
ask me
anytime you need help or you need
something you can come to us
don't worry we're here for you
and i'm so happy
nishimbere and hamisi were granted
asylum in 2017. their journey that began
in burundi has brought them home how
does it feel to be so warmly embraced by
detroit
that's why we say this right in yambani
that is our slogan this rate is home
we can't think in detroit enough we got
our
asylum here we got our kid here
we are operating a successful business
here
we are growing here
and so yeah detroit new york as as we we
say
for cbs mornings i'm niti chen in
detroit
michigan boy sounds like when you're in
detroit you need to go to baba fair
that's right i love the back story and i
like the food i'm originally from
seattle but i spent four years in
detroit and enjoyed it
thank you nancy